somehow EKG analysis is perceived as
mundane by a lot of clinicians in the
communities that we interact with so we
help them removes mundane part of the
job
and really focus on the cases that do
require medical attention I'm Ian flour
I'm the co-founder and CEO of cordials
and I'm 29 basically Kellogg develops
medical grade artificial intelligence
for cardiac Diagnostics so in short we
do help physicians who are not experts
to get closer to expedite gnostics and
we do help experts basically to be more
efficient and to do basically more
procedures in the same time our disease
is still the first cause of death in the
world I mean 18 million people die
prematurely every year due to cardiac
disease and the electrocardiogram in
itself is the most basic cardiac sensor
it's widely available all across the
world and in a lot of different areas in
the world especially in emerging
countries so if there is no expertise to
read properly the EKG well I mean the
examination itself is pointless I mean
by democratizing access to expertise in
EKG analysis we do raise the standards
of cardiac care at scale globally so I'm
not a doctor I'm a computer science and
biology engineer who you know gap I
would say get educated to the problem
right of you know doctor struggling to
read 3d kgs and somehow to me when
you're an engineer kind of trained to
answer to the question can something be
done while you know the interpretation
my son is more like should it be done
and once I mean a problem is worse being
solved then we'll see to which degree we
can effectively do it well I think that
that macron even before becoming
president as a minister of economy did a
lot to faster there's a syrup
environment in Paris and now I mean
there is a whole ecosystem of
early-stage startups a few of them are a
growing to attack you know Series A
Series B scaling into global leaders
mini corridors is practice a is one of
these companies but we also have success
stories such as shift technology which
is doing AI for fraud detection so I
think that the ecosystem is getting more
matured the neck
generation of success stories in the
French ecosystem is still yet to yet to
arrive but it's coming soon
you